[Music]
hey what's up guys mkbhd here
and wrapping up a busy tech tober that
might sort of bleed into november a
little bit
apple just held today their second fall
event
in new york city for some of their most
creative products
i was just there just got back we got to
see the return of the macbook air
which was you could say long overdue but
it's even thinner than the original
but has a much better display and better
internal so that gets added to the
lineup
and they also dropped a new space grey
mac mini
again which was super long overdue but
with much improved power
and io so that's interesting but by far
the highlight of the show
was the last announcement which was the
brand new
ipad pro this had a lot of really
interesting things to me so when we
wrapped up we all got to go to this
hands-on area
i spent my time in that area with the
ipad pro so first thing you notice when
you get it in the hand
this is a complete redesign and we were
waiting for this basically a refresh to
make these ipads look
more modern and kind of like new iphones
if you will and i think they've
succeeded
there's two sizes still an 11 inch
screen or a 12.9 inch screen
and thanks to much thinner bezels as you
can see on all four sides
the 11 inch one is the same footprint as
the previous 10 and a half inch ipad and
the new 12.9 inch
has the shrunken bezels to be now
smaller and it's this super
boxy shape like the sides are almost
kind of sharp to hold like a macbook pro
and the entire chassis is 5.9
millimeters thick
which is ridiculous i don't know if the
battery is going to suffer for
this thinness but it's very striking to
look at
and to hold and it just kind of feels
like you're holding a display in fact it
is so thin
it now has a camera bump which kind of
ruins the possibility of it being like
this completely flat tablet on a flat
surface
also makes me question why even keep the
camera in the tablet but
people still use it to scan documents
and things like that so it's still there
and just the whole thing is so flat and
boxy which i really like it looks better
in person to me
than the slopier softer corners of the
old ipads
it's still an lcd panel but it's still a
very high resolution
it's also still that taller aspect ratio
so apps will be fine
but yeah the entire ipad with the
antenna lines and the speaker grille
cutouts
and the flat edges that can literally
stand it up by itself like that iphone 5
and 5s
in this new shell it just feels very new
there's also now no home button so
just face id but face id that works in
any orientation so no matter how you
hold the tablet
it will unlock which is dope and new
internals so it has a brand new a12x
bionic chip
with an eight core cpu and seven core
gpu
again a seven nanometer chip and it's
gotta be powerful enough to push all
these pixels but the ipad pro i already
used felt fast so it's kinda hard to
imagine this one
being even faster but it is i can't
forget about that 120 hertz refresh rate
also
that's still here and there's also now
more internal storage
starting at 64 gigs and going all the
way up to a
terabyte if you're into that and then
the shocker to me this is
i did not see this coming at all is this
new ipads have
usb type-c yes usb-c and an ipad pro
already so you can plug in usb-c
accessories you charge
by usbc and you can even now plug into
an iphone and charge that with the
ipad's battery over usb-c so clearly
apple sees the benefits of this port
in their pro tablet but wow that is
definitely a lot earlier than i thought
i'd ever be able to say we'd have
an ipad with usbc i'm not saying it's
giving me
hope for some other apple products to
get usbc as much as i want to usbc all
the things
but i'd say my hope level for a new
iphone with usbc just went from like
zero percent to one percent so that's
good also you might remember the apple
pencil and the really unfortunate
charging situation with lightning
in the old ipad pro well with no
lightning port that's obviously gonna
have to change instead
this is way better the new apple pencil
has
magnets and a flat side and a dedicated
spot on the side of the ipad pro
where it just snaps on pairs and
wirelessly charges right there
way better than the last one plus the
new pencil now has a touch sensitive
area at the bottom that supports taps
and double taps
so you can double tap in the notes app
for example to switch between the tools
and the eraser and it looks like
third-party apps will be able to support
this too
when it comes out so there was a
photoshop demo on stage
that use this tapping for zoom and
there's also a new smart keyboard case
of course
i'm not the biggest keyboard user with
my tablet but i know a lot of people out
there are so the one thing that's
missing
and you've probably noticed it by now by
how many times i've turned the tablet
around
there is no headphone jack just usbc is
the only port on the new ipad pro
no headphone jack and look with a tablet
i think there's
obviously enough space in a tablet to
just toss in a headphone jack
with apple it's not really about the
space anymore it's just about them
systematically throughout their lineup
getting rid of the headphone jack where
we don't seem to need it anymore so
we'll see them keep it around longer in
like desktops and laptops and places
where it's definitely
more often used but yeah this is a
bummer for if you're
like a dj who relied on having a
headphone jack in the ipad or if you're
a music editor or a video editor on the
ipad pro
you'll probably want to go pick up the
old one but this isn't a deal breaker
for me i'm already kind of a wireless
person anyway
and also for when you're at home the
speakers are usually pretty good so
overall my thoughts
just from the first impressions of
holding it this is the best tablet on
the planet
and it's not like that's a surprise
because the ipad is one of
pretty much three tablets that are
actually still worth buying but for me
like when new tablets come out like when
the pixel slate came out for example
i immediately just start to stack it up
to the ipad like can you
take sales from the ipad if you beat it
if you don't beat it no one's going to
buy it and it kind of feels like with
this new ipad pro
that gap just got even wider for
everyone to catch up to so i'm pretty
pumped about it
i'm gonna be picking one up it's also
going to be expensive like the ipad pro
has been for a while
it's going to be starting at 7.99 for 64
gigs
and uh you can go on apple's site right
now and you can spec all the way up to
1 899
for one terabyte 12.9 inch ipad pro with
lte
just for fun i guess but let me know
what you guys want to see in the full
review
i'm going to be getting my hands on this
soon and putting it through its paces
so make sure you subscribe to ready if
you're not to see that when it comes out
either way thanks for watching this
first impressions hope you enjoyed
catch you guys in the next one peace